Jeremy started Jeremy is a colleague of
ours in social studies
who teaches at the University of William
and Mary and he is currently the chair
or from sorry he is the supervisor for
the program in secondary social studies
as he only to earlier
he's a former middle school teacher also
a professional development coordinator
in his previous life and currently is an
assistant professor at the College of
William and Mary
his research focused on the intersection
of media pedagogy and curriculum and
he's actually working on a new book on
teaching his friends with the editors
yeah yes teaching history with the
marketing people changed it to be really
bland and honestly I can't remember it's
something literally like teaching
history with film and I was a reviewer
of this book and it was a terrific book
so I encourage you to check it out when
it gets on Amazon or in the local stores
so in January very good so please
welcome Jeremy starter and as both side
that wasn't metal school teacher so if
you do questions I had point go ahead
and feel free to yell at me and I also
did that tech professional development
for a few years and 35 school districts
in Wisconsin so I was the person on the
Friday afternoon when everyone wanted to
get their roofs preparing for the first
day of school I was the person forcing
them to be in the hot cafeteria doing
workshops so I've had very tough
audiences so that again feel free to
yellow
if you want every night I did one of the
colonial ones Burkett's teacher
institutes in the summer and so I did a
session on a Friday night and I met them
with dinner person they were drinking
heavily and dinner and then I'm supposed
to do this session I'm teaching with the
film afterward and they were quite good
but it was a very lively session at
least I think that's actually in a
number of ways one teaching I was really
interested in how film was used in what
kids were actually learning from it
because I had the teachers next door to
me you're the one that taught the Civil
War perform loans and would show punch
of films I was wondered well what are
students really getting out of it and
see the detailed worksheets people use
and have them may see to keep kids
watching the film
right I saw there was a big distraction
away from actually trying to get
something out of it so I've been doing
research on this for a while now and the
Vietnam connections interest in the
first film that I made as part of video
production class was a documentary on
Vietnam that was my stepdad was a
fighter pilot in Vietnam was shot down
twice in North Vietnam and he's a little
sweet so he makes it sound like it was a
good time being you know will inaudible
playing at hundreds of miles an hour but
she was also rescued by among detachment
that was working for the CIA on one of
the occasions and I was in st. Paul at
the time of teaching in st. Paul
Minneapolis where there's a huge moment
population so friends of mine met we're
teaching history in st. Paul he's been a
number of times in it but it brought up
the whole issue of the treatment of the
Hmong after the war and then all sorts
of things that were going on there but
the one thing the kids really got a kick
out of this you would say come on my
stuff that would and so they would kind
of giggle every time he would say how
long so that was my first foray into
into video production
and it made me more critical I think of
looking at documentaries because I know
I was grabbing stock but had nothing to
do with what I was doing to trying to
illustrate what he was saying in video
so it gave me a sense more of the of the
choices that documentary film makers
make it's that we're going to talk a
little bit about today and also with the
rise of reality television the ability
of anyone in their garage with a
computer to make a documentary film now
you know all these things there's a lot
more back to our new films out there and
from some of the research that have done
a lot more in the classroom so we're
looking at kind of the social role what
documentaries are in terms of how people
learn history and then also look at how
they can use in the classroom and
hopefully we'll pass on some things be
that you can think about as you're going
through in selecting clips and how
you're and using in the classroom and so
I thought this the History Channel
effect not to pick on the History
Channel but I happen to be standing
through a lot late in and somewhat
horrified by what's on the History
Channel now including it up so don't
refer to later those blogs out the
problems of having sex in space I'm not
what are there programs that my wife is
addicted to Monster quest including the
New Jersey so these things all in the
History Channel and Ice Road Truckers or
whatever it is and all that so because
of some of the things I've seen in class
we're really raised it for me so not to
pick on the History Channel but a little
bit so one of the first things we we
looked at - and this is a friend of mine
Alan Marcus and ice about seven years
you don't want to find out well how many
films are being used in classroom which
films are being used and there was
nothing on it there was some data on
numbers out using the classroom that
different films are being used but
nothing really more specific so we
looked at it and this is a pretty small
survey but as history teachers in
Wisconsin
and we found and again people who
respond to surveys tend to be people who
really care about it so it's probably a
little high but even then it was
shocking to us that basically 93% said
they used all our part and most of my
finger probably clips of a feature film
once a week or more and 83% of
documentary once a week or more okay now
these could be you know they used the
little you know history in the day thing
at the beginning of each period or
something as a warm-up we don't really
know the exact details of it but they're
using them there's a lot of felonies
being up and being used out in the
classroom doing research on students and
what they're getting out of it this is
where someone for some studies but also
where it's appearing in other parts of
the literature basically found this what
I'm calling the History Channel side and
I'll just read quickly it's the belief
many young people have that all forms of
documentary because event this isn't
just kid just as people in general
documentary from the video are objective
and neutral sources of historical
information and infliction where people
are unable to recognize the value Laden
ideological perspectives in most
documentary-style film and this was from
research of asking students well what is
the point of the film what do they want
you to believe about it and they would
have no clue unless you have some then
to go and say well what do you think the
plain view is the person that makes it
what how does it make me if you think a
little deeper then they can start to
figure out but naturally they aren't
looking for kind of the perspectives of
it and so I'm looking at this from four
different kind of parts that form
together this effect one of this kind of
epistemic was the belief about the
nature of knowledge that
commander e equals objectives in most
people's minds a second part is the role
of the social role of media in terms of
where we learn our history from and some
of this is including the one article you
reading from Sam Weinberg and curve
right that was on your left they talk a
little bit more about this in their
piece in terms of the role of film a
third part of the way a teachers in
authority figures use film that's
actually supporting this notion that
documentaries are objective and the
fourth is this this kind of phenomenon
in the last 10 15 years that making
documents become so much cheaper so much
easier to do that the quality of them in
a lot of cases in one way it's really
democratizing in terms of it allows
groups that haven't been able to have
you know cuz it took a lot of money to
make film they've been able to actually
bring their voices in on the other hand
there's also a whole lot of more garbage
out there and and it's it's hard for
students and even teachers I think
sometimes to look at the quality of a
documentary in which case I'm saying
well look at everything as being kind of
from a certain perspective and then that
helps a little bit but there's some
exercises we're gonna get into later on
in the session that'll get at it and so
this isn't necessarily anything new in
terms of that documentaries are biased
it's all indication there's a whole
field of educational film analysis that
that talks about you know the old you
know anything from some of the the
family consumer science formerly polemic
films that were very gender Laden in
terms of the themes are put out there
from educational films on trying to
think you know even from the little
turtle 1 under the nuclear trying to
hide in the desk you know there's
there's all sorts of things that we know
even though
thumbs have a lot of bias to it but I
think it's been really amplified in
today's society because we're using it
so much more so the first one the
epistemic D is a documentary film and
this is literally when you start talking
with students and you have some what
what did you like about the documentary
film or why you know which one do you
think is more trustworthy these are the
things that you're going to start seeing
they're more trustworthy it's accurate
it's the truth it's real it's neutral
which is something we heard a lot more
complete it's the real history it's
nothing nothing that's as compared to
feature film which they will recognize
as being not real although they'll still
sometimes talk about it as if it is real
but there's some issues there too and
historian Robert Rosen stone bass
explains of this way he says the claim
is that we can see and presumably feel
with people in the past song well this
is what people do when they're watching
documentaries but that's hardly the case
for we can always see and feel much that
the people in the photos and newsreels
could not see that their clothing on
wheels were old-fashioned and that the
landscape black skyscrapers and other
contemporary buildings that their world
was gone was black and white and hunting
and dawn and so basically what he's
saying is when we watch the documentary
we're always watching it from our values
or understanding from the present and
what happened and so therefore we can
never truly kind of feel what they felt
but it gives us the sense that we might
be able to in the same way that watching
the film on the Holocaust might tend to
give you the belief that you know a
little bit more about what it would have
been to experience that or any other and
so this is the tricky part
so as a looking round again on the
History Channel I flipped through a lot
one of the things that included and a
lot of us is included
article that's posted for the thing
that's in that I've been working on one
of the things I noticed was a lot of
commercials for a particular video
series and this video series happens to
be the same one that the cut film that
you're working with
I come from they've been pushing this
something in a lot lately
and how it's described in the commercial
is this is the real Vietnam without the
spin without the bias all right an
objective look into the Vietnam turmoil
and even compares itself you know this
is the real bit now I'm not like all
those other things that are out there so
even in the ads that we're seeing
they're positioning it as being
objective as being the real Vietnam and
I think you have to look at all this
stuff in within the social context of
what it's made to is that someone talked
about earlier Americans bill looking at
no 1981 when this TV series was on it
was very close you know still this is
when Hmong and Vietnamese refugees are
still coming over you know this isn't
too many years out from when US soldiers
and personnel that were left kind of
they're working still that are still you
know coming over or coming back within
you know four or five years after this
so it's still pretty fresh in everyone's
mind so when we watch it today you
probably get a very different look at it
than then and I thought to make this
point I'm going to show you the
beginnings of a couple of feature films
to show you also how a kind of the
social and cultural values of when they
were made really reflects in the film so
we're gonna show a couple clips your
classics where I start with the Green
Berets which how many people have seen
the Green Berets so this is 1968 and
it's very much I wouldn't say this is a
completely a broad social view but it
reflects at least a certain segment of
society at the time and we're just gonna
watch the introductory kind of first
chapter here
if that's re made to see if this will
work
so I want you answers as we're playing
this just kind of get your junk
instinctive of what you would make them
at the time between 1968 urine theater
watching what are they trying to get you
to think about from the sill okay we're
going to stop there so and I want you
remember that laughing the training part
because we're in compared to another
film that came out later which is a
little different version of the boot
camp experience what types of feelings
and things does this clip bring up
especially from watching it from today
again this was released in 68 such a
strong sense of earnestness of cause I
mean you know clearly on the side of
right very earnest about our mission you
know we have this name to accomplish and
you know there's no skepticism about
anything what else
and maybe just some dumb way in
connotation but a westerns in a kind of
painting the frontier from
yeah the song is very illustrative
that's why I'm going to play the opening
credits for you what else well I think
along the lines of it being very clear
that it's right the use of German
perhaps to call back and say you know
yeah you listed it was surprising me
when I was watching this again because
about half woman said to speak Norwegian
and I was thinking in the Cold War why
would they all be speaking Norwegian you
know today that it says no context for
why we would need soldiers to speak
Norwegian right now it'd be you know
Farsi in and you know Arabic that may be
speaking the pendant like happen to
speak Norwegian they keep going through
all those attachment what else what are
the things that kind of bring up in you
is this like the Vietnam when you think
of Vietnam films this is this what you
picture no it isn't is it it actually
feels more like a World War two film
might have come out to two decades
earlier you know with a very a very
competent well disciplined detachment of
soldiers you sort of have one soldier
representing each ethnic group or each
culture and then you have the tough
no-nonsense but also sort of humorous
laid-back commander represented by John
Wayne and it feels more like something
that would have come out in the late
1940s as opposed to nineteen six it's
definitely it's a war film genre and
kind of that world war ii feel to it
rather
it actually gets more so to get into the
movie I build into it what else the
drove same thing yeah so definitely it
feels like a different era and you think
today of kind of Vietnam War film this
probably isn't what you're picturing but
this is what was coming on in 1968 and
this is something one the other I think
I gave you that book chapter right the
after-party one woman yeah she wrote a
bunch a chapter and she called them the
version that came out kind of 1980s all
these films that were made the noble
grunt John because it reflected a
different societal view and so I'm going
to show just the brief opening part of
one of those this here bear with me for
a moment
and so you definitely see a big shift in
terms of views of both soldiers and the
war I think when you look at the later
Jean roof films which includes films she
writes about a kind of looking at
especially a platoon ever no
full-metal-jacket try to remember the
other ones that Chaim cludes in there
and so I'm going to show you a short
clip from Full Metal Jacket
there's no there isn't
shoes so I wanted to show the trailer
in your laptop yeah I'll do that quick I
didn't want to show you the trailer
because the trailer kind of does the
trick for us so as I do that I will
continue to babble but after Heidi's um
arguments which I think you'll see in
Full Metal Jacket you probably get more
sense up is in that period in the late
eighties you get into the same mode that
things still kind of exists today when
you see the Iraq war films which is very
supportive of the soldiers that are
there even if the film overall is kind
of against the war itself and I think
you still see that a lot in the films
today when you see this newest group of
thumbs are coming out
in a second to load here
probably said too many ways to use the
stuff are they alright so now keeping in
mind what we just saw with John Wayne
we're see a little different version
here ok so right now we're gonna watch
this the opening part of this too but
right away what mood you get from that
trailer that's different from the Green
Berets what media that you see is
different
right definitely the board's the
humanizing and also that the grunts on
the ground don't seem to have much
respect with their commanding officers
for a bunch of stuff shirt blowhard it's
very different from John Wayne the
Marella commander who can rally
everybody together yeah so there's
definitely a different different look in
terms of soldiers and officers and who's
in charge and what their what their
goals aren't that definitely right what
else went on
the issue of the chain of command in
Cooper does a great job
explosion sort of populist sentiment
underneath with the truths that generate
a lot of that and now and some of it is
of course you know green brains would be
much more professional soldiers where
this is reflecting drafting so there is
a little bit of a difference in the
story being told but the automatic mood
you get is very different right the war
is lost whereas you wouldn't get that we
the Green Berets so this is the opening
sequence response a little bit so again
think of so compare the two John Wayne
is yelling out to this detachment who's
in training and they're yelling back you
know or airborne whatever and then you
open go to the opening sequence of this
and one of these guys look like writers
are getting their head spin doesn't look
like sheet man's the swatter a little
bit what else I mean obviously Stanley
Kubrick has a particular vision in mind
he's making this film right what else
did you know what else kind of gives you
a sense of mood to see more really the
way people really speak
a lot of propaganda late it's cleanse
them the
dirty okay a little like Eli's much
again the world war two genre like the
older World War two films were very much
that way too it looks like you're
watching an ad for it almost I think
with music was yeah and you have a
different use of music that are right
especially prepared the first one which
is this Green Berets you know very
glorification this is the guy who make
dr. Strangelove so you know even though
time has passed from the Green Berets to
disco he was kind of there already oh
definitely you know yeah right so what
this gives you is two things one is you
know the social perception of the war
and how that shifted the other part you
see are the two the way the perspectives
of the people making the films is very
different right you have John Wayne
velocity comes from a particular
political view and Stanley Kubrick who's
coming from a very different view so you
see two effects of two different things
one in the social period and these are
the people in the kind of the time
reflecting the time they're making it
the other one is you know the people who
are doing the writing selecting the
scenes putting it together have a big
control over what it's going to look
like as well so that's one thing I want
you to kind of keep thinking about you
know the next time your class and you're
thinking well I need to show a film on
this event
you're not just selecting a film because
it shows the certain of that right
you're selecting a film because it shows
a certain perspective on that event
there are 300 and some you know civil
war films Gloria was the first one that
showed anything on the african-american
soldiers perspective after you know I
think it's a 300 I camera
number of old films made so you know
you're picking something not just
because it's about a time period or
event you're picking it because it shows
a certain perspective so that's one of
the big kind of takeaways at least that
I've gotten out of the research I've
done we're going to go back okay so a
little bit of a break away from the
documentary but I do that because
documentaries do very much the same
thing they reflect the social period the
political views of the people who make
them the ideological views of the people
who make them and they're making a lot
of the same decisions in a documentary
albeit with some kind of this raw
material that they are in future films
so there isn't that much difference
especially in newer documentaries
because they've actually adopted a lot
of the same kind of narrative structures
of feature films in terms of way the
story is being told so that's one thing
also to kind of keep in mind and so I
did have to look quickly ahead looked up
Roger Ebert wrote a review of the Green
Berets and I wanted to share this
because he picks out even there was a
critical element at that time and he
wrote the Green Berets this is 1968
simply will not do as a film about the
war in Vietnam it is offensive not only
to those who oppose American policy but
given that those who support it
at this moment in our history locked in
the longest and one of the most
controversial Wars we've ever fought
what we certainly do not need is a movie
depicting getting on in terms of cowboys
and Indians this is cruel and dishonest
unworthy of the thousands who have died
there so you know even at that time done
with a little late right it's a you get
the sense that at least in the media the
tide has turned a little bit and this is
after 10 it came out in 68 that was
January 68 was Ted Wright new year and
so this is the film came out after the
so it's interesting timing wise in terms
of what the two films show but one of
the things I found was this one's
calling the History Channel effect is
really ingrained in students minds all
right spend a little bit of time looking
at why so this was a part of a study I
did this was actually unit on World War
two and I asked him to rank for the
different sources that use as part of
the unit in terms of which ones they
would trust and documentary film came
out to be the most trustworthy source
that they had above textbooks even so in
students Minds and again depending on
how the teachers using it they really
take these as very trustworthy objective
sources of information and this is a
pure Ashima the decision dropped the
bottom which I don't know if you've seen
there now it's a very powerful
documentary on and it does give kind of
reasons on both sides of the use of the
atomic weapons but the image is really
powerful against in terms of the victims
of the of the nuclear bombs and the
destruction of them so with a little
more data on that coming a little bit
later so the second part or factor them
saying is is in this history channel
effect is the nature of watching
historical documentaries so how are we
socially involved in watching
documentaries or these types of films
and what we found is they've become to
some degree essential part of where a
lot of people are learning their history
from we're not seeing kids aren't going
out and reading a book if they're
talking about something in history class
what I kept seeing in the studies I've
done is the teacher would say well where
did you get that from or where did you
see that and the two answers were either
it came from like a parent and older
relative something to that effect or it
came from a film or the History Channel
or something like that these are the
things that kept coming up time and time
again
same thing wine Mercado and back to
Rosen stone he said that in his mind
document films are doing more
problematic as historical sources
because even historians journalists and
the general public are much more
trusting so we see both the trustees
view of what that would means to be a
documentary and also the social role now
that documentary films hold and here's a
little that this is one of the
interviews I was doing students in the
study and she was talking about I was
asking where they learned their history
from and what they liked and she said
well my grandpa's really into history
and so I talked to him a lot about it he
kind of got me interested in it I
watched the DVD on World War two that my
grandpa bought for me I like to watch
that one a lot and so what she kept
talking about was as they're sitting
socially talking about these films the
parents or grandparents are talking
about their experiences during this time
and there it even lays more weight to
what's being shown in the documentary
okay and this is especially on Vietnam
and this is what Weinberg and those
folks found was that generations are
talking about history while they're
watching the film and so it's actually
needing more credence to it as a
historical source and it's this female
student went further and said I'd like
to see all the old footage because it is
what actually happened so this view of
documents is coming out it sounds like
somebody acting it out you get to
actually see it I like to watch all the
old planes and people I don't know it's
just interesting so again we're seeing
both the views and that's a social
connection and what white urban and
folks in the article that you're reading
they will not even say that historical
community writ large still doesn't want
to believe that films actually have
what people know about the past or that
they can be works of history in
themselves which is what Rosen stone
would argue and so they included this
part which I thought was good he said
even historians such as the president of
the Organization of American stronger
grudgingly recognized films the
predominant influence on students
historical understanding rather than
pretending that we can do away with
popular culture we might try instead to
understand how its forces can be
marshaled rather than spurn or simply
ignored and this is cuz they kept
finding the film that popped up in their
study was for Scott that what they're
referring to when they're talking about
Vietnam was actually farce gone which is
problematic on all sorts of levels right
but after popular film pg-13 it wasn't
like Full Metal Jacket where the guys
you know swearing every other word and
violent and so many people saw it and so
they're talking about the history that
was you know flipped into Forrest Gump
and and it was a very central to all
these people's to all these families
discussions they actually went out to
households and talked to multiple
generations of people in their study the
third part then of of this History
Channel effect is the technological
advances and your project is a good
example of this right twenty years ago
there wasn't a streaming server that can
have hundreds of hours and cut footage
that all these people could access
instead you could have one guy in a
basement in Boston who could look
through the old you know the film reel
footage and tape it together so we've
got huge advances and how documentaries
can be made and huge advances in how
they can be distributed which has a lot
of pluses I think for us as teachers but
it's also got some limitations in terms
of being able to evaluate these things
one thing that I've found a lot lately
is because of the filtering policies in
a lot of schools they aren't able to
bring in video from some of these other
groups that have been able to produce
films they can't bring in things that
then created by teachers and posted on
YouTube they can't do that but what they
are bringing in is things like United
streaming which gives them by using the
United streaming in New York do you know
what that does it's basically a big
video database from like the Discovery
Channel all those and that you can go in
and search and bring little clips up
kind of like the system that you saw but
if all these commercially produced
documentaries so again this is where
they're drawing all their sources from
and you don't even know the context of
the video then you just search ten
offensive and you would get five clips
that have 30 seconds or a minute or
whatever of information on the ten
offensive and that's what they're strong
in their classes and so that has some
some problems in it kind of all of its
own and so what we're seeing especially
on places like The History Channel
effect so this is what you used to have
to have to make film okay
now you've got this or I ended this
video all right so now you're able to
access and use it you know in much the
same way and what's all this work and
all this equipment twenty years ago and
so this is the problem places like the
in places like the History Channel
because as I mentioned before these are
the types of things you're seeing so you
might see something on if you're
watching The History Channel on the Ohio
grassman another one classic
Loren's we like it down in our part of
the world the chassis which is the Loch
Ness monster in the Chesapeake Bay or a
dr. memory on cold cut production
featuring the olive loaf I saw this one
too or what I think is the most
interesting which is an episode of the
universe which was on the difficulties
when we make the mission to Mars of
actually physically having sex in space
and it's very physiologically difficult
to pull off so this is what kids are
seeing when they turn the History
Channel and one of the issues is as I
spent on the classes observing student
teachers one of my cooperating teachers
as an extra credit assignment was to go
and watch something through the History
Channel and just write about what you
saw no differentiation of what that show
was on the History Channel but just the
History Channel is mentioned as one of
the things and in other there's been a
number of other articles that have
brought up the same thing that they're
praising students for watching The
History Channel in class that when it
comes up this is the reaction of
teachers and so we have to keep in mind
that which brings us to the fourth part
is how we're positioning students in the
classroom the documentaries and how
we're using it so if you're praising
students for watching The History
Channel what they might be watching you
know this champ right the Lake Champlain
monster on Monster quest
okay every whatever else isn't our most
addictive remember
and so the study that I did was in these
two teachers and I wanted to bring it
back to the Vietnam part one of the
documentaries they used which we're
going to use some scenes from later with
letters home from Vietnam which was an
HBO production as am i familiar with
this one it was an HBO production I just
saw the same guy did the letters from
Iraq which I haven't seen but it was
basically from soldiers who died their
letters home was how the video was
structured around it with famous actors
reading the letters with a whole bunch
of things inter-communal and you'll see
it but this is the way this is the
reasoning that the two teachers of my
study this is why they selected it and
what I think you what they found out as
we were going to run the study was films
they were selecting were films that they
liked which happened to reflect their
views but they were using them in the
classroom very objectively and again
part of it was disbelief is because it's
a documentary therefore it's okay to do
that by the end when I was talking with
about it they started to say oh yeah it
does kind of show my views but you know
there really isn't anything else out
there that shows another view okay
that's the types of things that it's
saying but the two teachers one said I
think that letters through Vietnam this
is why they're so I think continues the
whole stream of consciousness about wars
bad words parentis and the other one
who's much more blatant about her views
to show that the war was really messed
up in a real big struggle from almost
every person's point of view that's not
even close to being accurate is it so
also what we're seeing is the reflection
of this is something else from the
Weinberg side that's interesting they
would want look and students today the
way textbooks are structured to would
believe that the majority of the
population in the United States was
against the war like in 1968 and that's
just really not true at all right so
it's also the way the collective memory
run in Vietnam interesting too because
what they've seen are these films and
things that have come out that really
have this an time
more spin to them so now this is what
they told their students when they're
gonna show this and both of them use the
film and then wanted students to
deliberate on what their position on the
Vietnam War would have been so take a
look and see how their Pacific their
students so mrs. Johnson said keep in
mind this is what Jackie said in class
keep in mind that many of the boy
through were going to see in the film
were 18 19 years old that's like three
years older than you guys so I want you
to kind of think about what would have
been like for you and how it feels this
is the first war where we have the
technology of reporters on the ground
following the troops so all the footage
is real those are actual soldiers those
are people getting filled in shot being
carried in and she acts you want
students at the end to say you know
would you Bend against it or for it at
the end of Watchmen was filmed with the
film being the largest part of
information on Vietnam or that they're
going to get the other teacher again a
little more blatant and she actually
gave him a worksheet that that had these
compelling reasons and had been listed
look for at least three psychological
sociological and practical reasons for
why the US was destined to lose the
Vietnam conflict so right away she's
positioning students this way and she
actually asked the students at the end
to say would you have enlisted would you
have followed the draft if you were
drafted would you have a camera Burling
protested or ran away or something else
and she realized that word does a bad
question because all the female students
in her class wouldn't have been ready to
draft anyway so it's a bad item but but
this is how she's framing students to it
basically saying you know look for all
these reasons why I was destined to lose
and then decide if you're supported or
not okay but it's not the question so
it's kind of an open question and and
they're giving them the right answer and
so at the end I asked two
the point of view of the people who made
the film and what I frame it it is
really interesting so you can tell in
the two classes and this was both for
the hiroshima film in four letters these
were the responses of the number of
students in the class so four letters
about half the students decided it was
anti-war another a little over a third
set into neutral which live in seven
pounds because it had something from
kind of what they saw as both points of
view therefore it was balanced some said
it was for the war and when you see the
film this is really an interesting take
on it although when I started talking
with them I won't mention where this
study was done but let's just say that
in head of our largely big history with
with the anti-war movement - a lot of
the parents in fact one who said his
mama's tear gas what I found was that
the ones who said it was actually
supported on the war was because the
film was much more positive than what
they heard at home that they sought
therefore as supportive of the war so
it's all kind of context related in
terms of what they were hearing at home
this was a much even though this is
really an anti-war kind of film it was
still more positive than what they saw
so it's all very context related in
terms of when you get to your students
okay so we have these four kind of ways
of leading what I'm calling this History
Channel five and then I was thinking
what the heck are teachers supposed to
do about it so we're looking at a number
of different ways and they all kind of
center around basically critical
literacy goals
and the first and easiest is for us as
teachers to stop looking at
documentaries as objective notions of
documentary okay and what I did really
think a lot about is trying to get
teachers to think more about what
documentary filmmakers are trying to do
what are their goals in making these
films because they have a real specific
reason for doing it and they do think
they want to be in education they want
them to be used in education but when
they would say they aren't just telling
the story of an event they would say
they're trying to tell a story that has
a particular view on the event and
Robert calls who did it work called
doing documentary work which is
interesting this is a really good book
he puts it this way says considered the
viewpoint may see of the documentarian
and he said they all often and he said
this is somewhat contained them
contentious but their attempt to
something that some of the narrative
side of the verb document as opposed to
it's more specific reference the
accumulation of designation of various
items is firm proof of something so
basically he's saying they aren't saying
they are trying to tell the objective
story of something they're trying to
frame a narrative that's interesting to
an audience that puts across a certain
perspective they don't think they're
being objective if you ask a documentary
filmmaker they wouldn't say there are no
educational film maybe but not
documentary film okay and so I think
this is one thing that we as teachers
need to think about too is the way that
we're framing it for students and so
we're gonna look at a few different ways
to do this so one is to get students to
think about the choices of the producers
of the film writers directors people are
doing the interviews people are
selecting the stock footage that they're
using the stock footage is really
problematic it's awfully is that the
context this is the reason why Holocaust
deniers have any usually this is one of
the
things that they use that images there's
millions and millions of pictures out
there that relate to the Holocaust but
yet when you see what's actually used in
publications and films it's a very very
small number because we've found these
iconic kind of images at the Holocaust
are used over and over again and the
problem is they're often used out of
context and so that opens the door for
Holocaust deniers to then say well that
picture wasn't in this city this was in
another city and therefore none of it's
true right I mean gives you a window
into it and so in the same way a lot of
documentaries they take a picture
because it's powerful that pick a stock
footage clip because it's very powerful
not because it necessarily relates
exactly to what they're saying and so
that's one thing
the selection of evidence that T's do we
look at a different Vietnam or a section
of the film that's on Vietnam the
filmmaker uses a very creative use of
multiple forms of evidence that he's
trying to make his point with visually
and auditorily audibly one of those
words you can cut that from the film so
really trying to get the the author's
perspective on it and also the audience
that they're trying to talk to okay so
John Wayne who is that 1968 film made
for
I am really who-who is he thinking of
when he was making that film okay
versus Stanley Kubrick when he's making
you know dr. Strangelove who is he
thinking when he's making that film who
are the intended audiences and and
what's the intended breed of it which is
these are kind of film studies things
but I think they can be helpful to think
through so we're going to do a number of
exercises and I'm gonna apologize in
advance that they're not the order
exactly a problem you use them but I
wanted to give you a packet of examples
of things these are the things that I've
used or that I've taken from teachers
who I've studied and then what they've
used or I use them a little bit
different ways but I wanted to give you
some examples of kind of activities you
can do in your class to help students to
start to think of some of the things
I've talked about and so the first one I
want to take you to is actually one of
the storyboards so to talk midway in
your packet there's two versions of it
you can pick either one one of the first
things in media literacy and when you're
when you're doing when you're actually
making film is to understand all the
decisions that go into making any piece
of film is to do a reverse storyboard so
do you know any prior a reverse
storyboard so you know the storyboard is
where they're gonna go through and plan
out the different scenes that they're
gonna have the text that's gonna be in
there the transitions are things that
are youth maybe the sound effects well
what I have them do is do a reverse card
word which means I show them a short
clip of something and record down what's
used from it so get them to think about
the choices in terms of the what's being
used in the sound what's being used in
the text what kind of ways are the is
the film spliced together are they
Shen's is a really rough cut and so one
of the best ways to do this is with ABS
because they're sharp and so today we're
going to use probably one of the most
famous ads that was only used once
which is a campaign that from 1964 and I
believe it was actually only run once is
that right does anybody know I think
that so this is the infamous Daisy girl
add something to that effect from 1964
from Lyndon Johnson's campaign let's see
if eminent and so what I want you to do
what this catches up is just humor me a
little bit and try in this very short
30-second commercial to do a reverse
scoring board of the different cuts that
you're going to get and actually you
have to do this you have to play it
multiple times with when you're doing it
with students because it takes a while
to do you should do it once without the
audio to get the visual part down and
then come back and be the audio paper
with me to try to see what he's using
here it's always interesting if you
don't use this site it's the living room
candidate and it has all the a lot of
ads from the first 150 to on and even if
one from Kennedy's campaign those only
shown in Spanish Harlem with Jackie's
speaking in Spanish which is a neat one
too
what do you see and I'm sorry it kind of
spelled but hopefully you got a sense of
it if you were looking at that what's
the transition that they use visually
kind of what happens in the scenes so
you start obviously with this girl and
looks your reaction to this girl what
are they trying to get across here she's
cute innocent all-american girl standing
into medal flowers all right exactly
you know this is Americana image right
and what's she doing she's mall
things right this is you know kind of
the site
Eli's version of life in a free America
although the math curriculum will work
on a little stone foundation for not
news and this year back in 60s - and
then what is what is the filmmaker doing
here in the ad maker doing to try to
start to get you think of the
seriousness of Italy - what is the
camera how does it cut - starts is zoom
right into our eye what message is that
sending do you think how does it make
you feel it's kind of like this idea
bearing witness to this potential for
destruction so it could be her future is
kind of gun Steve her future if you
don't choose Johnson what else
one nice thing about doing these in your
class when students get their takes on
it that you do start to hear the
different ways that people read things
which is always a good thing for
students to hear - that's not an
objective that people are looking at in
different ways what other reactions did
you have to that part so one is that
this could be your future
what other eyes you see something
through her eyes what else what do you
have to answer her with your decision
you know you're sort of
that your decision to vote or not vote
is they got you doing something to this
girl
great what else whatever other people's
readings on that
it's kind of a gut unnerving reaction
isn't that anytime you zoom in really
close on something it started either
trying to make you little nervous or
trying to shake you up a little bit okay
so then if she's counting down and then
goes to what what do you hear in the
background before Johnson what do you
hear as she's kind of counting down to
the flowers you start to hear what in
the background it might catch up you
start to hear countdown to what a
missile launch or something to that
effect right okay so they're they're
giving you the division of and then you
see the big mushroom cloud so if you
don't vote for Johnson what's gonna
happen nuclear holocaust right and then
you go to Johnson's voice which type of
Johnson's voice affect you this time so
then he says what we must all love each
other or we must die all right I mean
this is I mean we think of campaign ads
today people say our hearts they've
gotten I mean you start watching some of
these old ones it's really amazing okay
so they're very trying to get this
powerful image across you're looking in
Iran what you're seeing is a mushroom
cloud then you're saying well if you
want to see this you know if you don't
want to see this happen
vote for Johnson okay but in that little
30-second thing if you're gonna actually
pull out a storyboard for it you'd have
to fill out three or four different
little cutscenes wouldn't you there's a
lot that goes into the production of a
little short piece and the same thing
goes into longer documentaries we're
trying to get into in a second
we were warned by actually using the
nuclear weapon
it could be a hose only showed once I'm
not sure what in what context it was
showing I think it was so bad or
something you know it's sharp that that
they just pulled it because they got so
much negative feedback from it oh yeah
very well done yeah so that's kind of
one way to get at this idea of critical
literacy where I look at a couple of
different exercises down there a couple
other ways is to start to look at the
narrative structure of documentaries and
we're going to look at this time dear
America letters home through Vietnam but
what I want you to do and you can
reproduce these storyboards there's a
generic ones from somewhere but they can
be useful sometimes in the packet so you
have a few things here the first opening
page is we're going to use it a little
bit the second one this is a version
this is one of my former students that
use she uses an episode of The Twilight
Zone all monsters on Maple Street which
is really Red Scare kind of evocative up
and and sometimes the old TV series can
be nice because again it gives you this
feeling of the social in this case kind
of social criticism of the time but
they're made to be about 23 minutes long
it's a half hour episode - they're
they're pretty short you can use them
you know all in one 50-minute period so
this is the example what she used which
I gave it to because the second page one
of the things we've found in our
research is that you need to give
students a job during the viewing but
not necessarily answering really
detailed questions so you want to think
of a job it's gonna drive students to
watch the film closely and critically
and get what out of it what you want
them to versus kind of distracting them
away from it and so what she did here
was have them less
on this page what happened in the
episode and then how people reacted to
it because there's a number of these
events that happen along the way that
escalate as the it's the maple street
this little Maple Street USA kind of
side Dilek neighbor and as the neighbors
start turning on each other because of
what happened but Sochi anthem actually
watched them to film charting what was
going on so something like this is an
example of a good exercise during a film
the next part in here is the motion
picture analysis worksheet from the
National Archives as image is an example
they have one of these for all sorts of
different sources you might want to take
a look at those they're in the digital
classroom on the National Archive site
and then after the storyboards this is
the one that we're going to use and this
is actually an example I used with the
documentary in my class called I sit
where I want which is on the these
seconds students and buffalo high school
trying to desegregate their cafeteria
okay I use in my classes the raises all
sorts of issues in terms of both the
documentaries side and also issues of
kind of rates of segregation of the
impact of desegregation
it even has issues of like acting black
and those kinds of things that it's a
weason it's kind of a center point for
discussion but what I found was when I
try to do a discussion on a film and we
do static seminars is that you don't
have the text in front of you so you
need to find a way for students to
collect the data they need for the
discussion during the viewing and so
what I started to have them do to both
get up kind of the effective side of
what's going on and also this
information to refer back to was to
chart so every chunk of this film I
would have them record certain amounts
of data one with what actually happened
what they saw what they're kind of
effective of kind of the motions were
from it the impact
which is the feeling part and in the
thinking part so what questions did it
raise in their minds the other thing I
found with discussions of films is that
they would sit there and say well yeah
the big white guy and things like that
so that's why I started giving them a
chart with names on it and their
pictures so then when we had a
discussion they could actually say well
Mike what Mike did this it's a it's a
lot of times the discussion everyone who
could follow along I'm gonna have to
constantly describe things so if you are
going into a film discussion with a lot
of characters in it I would recommend
doing something where they can refer to
the people by names it's not gonna be
obvious well what we're gonna use this
chart for is I'm going to show you two
different clips out of letters home from
Vietnam one from the very beginning of
the film and one from about Midway and
what I want you to do we're going to
chart this just like we have here but
what we're going to look at is kind of
the progression of the narrative of the
documentary and how it's going to lead
us to kind of what what the filmmaker
wants you to feel about it and so I'm
going to show you two clips and so on
this one if you wanted to use the first
two blocks that are in there that would
be gray and there each one for me
and so this was put out making 87 and it
was an HBO production that they put
together and showed and like I said it
it was made basically centered around
all these letters of soldiers on this
show I think this includes the beginning
part and I want you to notice again how
they're describing the film and how
they're positioning kind of you as the
viewer to what you're seeing but this is
this would also kind of fit in that same
thing that the noble grunt vintage of
our genre of films okay so I want you to
take a minute and fill out those
sections on the turf they gave you in
terms of what you saw in the club your
reaction to it and maybe what questions
are raised
yeah you don't have to use the chart
you'll miss for a dollar department was
limping off we're going to scale it to
you some example
give me another minute or so to finish
this up
so before we move on to the second clip
what I want you to do is with a person
that's kind of next to you or near by a
group of three I want you to share with
each other kind of your impressions of
that first clip and we'll do a little
think pair share might a lot alike as
they did my students I always have to be
explicit about what I'm doing let them
know especially when I'm doing my
classroom management skills right I have
to go over there probably you two go
stand close to them and say what am i
modeling now and they both be quiet and
they realize that they can use proximity
hmm to make me be quiet when I want you
right now then it's just talk to them
and share with them what were your
reactions in terms of what you saw in it
how it kind of engaged you or hell made
you think about it and then what
questions are raised for you
um just to see what how each person is
going to see this a little bit
differently so take a couple minutes of
the person next to you to do that please
good
and they were playing on the boardwalk
just sort of do a good song everything
sixteen can that transition
these images warfare natality de
confusin
total rain Vietnam over here the cynical
line but
that said that
six things
Jenny I know that place
trust might be
yeah I know what they had this reaction
to hit up this music that heard these
the same stuff that they're right here
oh yes yeah holy
give you a couple minutes left in your
group to finish off of this first up
great fact we have the right
yeah
for sure
okay together
okay let's hear from a few of the groups
in terms of what were your reactions to
this first flow
okay what were some of your reactions
about the script back here what was your
reaction of this first club Sara I think
you know we all talked about the
contrast the beginning I mean I think
you know just the the idyllic scene of
young men enjoying themselves in the
beach and mellow music and then you know
cut to the rock music and receive an
event yeah so those two seems kind of
start you out going you know it get you
off balance a little bit almost showing
that this idyllic be to the surf and
kind of you know what what maybe people
at home were doing and then all the
sudden cuts to that what about the very
intro part today my did you read through
what was scrolling through their life
was very plain and
look you're a documentarian right and
the music was quite sad and the image
this image is solo image of the sky up
there kind of this antique
so that came along and then it really
cut very quickly to the surf scene exit
position was so strange but knowing
might usually things work in films you
are going to come back to the beginning
near the end at some point so they
already because I could precursor that
eventually yeah the front they tell you
right away that it's it's that these are
sold these are letters who soldiers that
died so it gives you a little bit as
bearing witness kind of thing that's an
end for you this is not a reenactment
and then they say they thank these
actors for yeah I got a kick out of that
so nothing in this nothing in this film
is reenacted this is all real footage
thanks to the actors who read you know
write the next paragraph had said that
so here they're setting you up saying
again this is real this is you know we
haven't been what they mean it's you
know obviously none of the footage has
been you know reenacted but these
letters are being read in a certain way
and it doesn't say anything about
footage being used out of context I mean
it shows those soldiers writing the
letters well did they really have film
of the actual people who they was
reading the backgrounds writing the
letters you know of course they didn't
they wouldn't farm film and pincode from
the stock footage to to show that to
support what they're showing in the film
right okay what are the reactions that
people have from the other groups
anything different
just with the use of the CCR song just
the question of who is serving in this
war just terms of prestige and the
critique and I guess the drive yeah
definitely this film uses music very
happily two very powerful effect I would
say especially kind of popular music I
don't know if that's the HBO thing or
what it is but the one reaction I got
from the students that were in the study
I did because this film was used in it
and because of where they were you know
it was the music they heard their
parents playing at home because it was
this group of parents that happened we
heavily anti-vietnam you know those are
the songs they identified with so the
kids in class really got into the film
in part they said because they
recognized a lot of the music that was
in it alright so now we're gonna watch
the second section and you wanna kind of
do the same thing and what we're going
to kind of think about is this is the
way you get your students to think about
how films are structured to have tell
this story over the course of the films
and break it into smaller pieces and
give their reactions at different points
so this is a this is about the middle of
the film I think maybe a little bit
towards the end okay do the same thing
here then
kind of record your reaction to this
little Club
okay let's go ahead and start from
cutting up a little short but let's go
ahead and do the same thing talk to the
person or people right around you and
share what your reactions were to disk
lift then we'll just you know like I
said a little bit past halfway I think
through the through the film and notice
here they're using the same close-up on
the I think that was something that to
show the emotion and show that to throw
it off a little bit so take a few
minutes to talk with people right around
you about this what what it caused
minutes
the music interprets
constantly really constructor me as it
once was happy we're going to liberate
these people in society whose body the
most was probably felt that way maybe
those letters
right
really good I one more summer to get to
one more activity but what quickly what
reaction do you have to this Film Club
and notice again we have a little bit
between the two scenes kind of there was
a there's a real message that starts to
build here I think is even though you
were watching short clips you start to
see kind of how the different parts are
connected and what the author of the
film wants to do what was your reaction
to this one it felt very strongly
anti-war because there's a juxtaposition
of images of soldiers being evacuated
from the battlefield injured soldiers
with the Marvin Gaye song what's going
on which clearly has an anti-war
perspective and the letters that were
hearing are only from soldiers who feel
very disillusioned and humanized by the
experience of it was section of the film
right they got from the first part of it
Basie says you know any questions war
you know I'm not questioning this more
of a war in general and then the next
part goes to kind of consequences of
this war right you see my leg you see
basically soldiers who are talking about
basic PTSD right they're talking about
deep hollow about drinking doing that so
it's kind of the consequences of both
you have soldiers and on the Vietnamese
the consequences of war right so that
must've starts to build in these this
kind of segment here definitely very
strong I'm just curious are there any
moments in the film where you hear
letters from people who felt a real
sense of confidence and purpose being
near a little bit more
kind of you know like the ones that you
heard at the beginning was a little bit
more of that you know like they have
some purpose of being there but not too
much okay
no not too much if I remember right now
it's been a while since I've watched the
whole thing
have you seen no I I understand looking
up something on the director I noticed
that one of the other films was letters
letters from Iraq or something so we
were saying guard was saying because we
read Lizzy's warn things that carry
we've all been sort of immersing
ourselves in this genre that everyone is
a theme that being haunted of being
perplexed like that very quizzical face
of that government like what's this all
about why am I here and you surely don't
get that sense from other war films that
that I see although and this is 1987
again this view of the synthetic honour
of films that's because all these issues
of all these vets not have come home all
these things are arising in societies
kind of the impact of what the war head
of the folks that did come home and
that's really reflected in this film
right at least that aspect of it but
trying to also be more sensitive to the
bedside there and the issues they're
going through too you know and this was
the interesting thing why Percodan bomb
because because they were using Forrest
Gump the image they were getting with
that everyone in society looked at these
soldiers and baby killers and that and
while there might have been a little bit
of that going on you know not everyone
in the u.s. looked at returning soldiers
is bad people are this right I mean
there were a lot of parts in the states
that were still pretty supportive of of
the soldiers at least coming home
not the war itself but but the in their
image from the film it was very much you
know they were all baby killers but if
they were doing that to show that you
know when these guys came home they did
have a rough time but they had a rough
time in it over there and they shouldn't
be treated that way right and so this
definitely reflects that kind of descent
in society now in the 80s that people
are recognizing that this is an issue
the veterans that are coming home and
then they're brought a lot of baggage
home that people that return simply
never ever spoke with what happened
there in any detail and I think the 80s
was really a sort of coming to grips
with that for the first time publicly
and I read this film it's an attempt to
do that as a nation what was going on
and you go back to murder all the World
War two vets that were out there that
was the good war that's now you know the
greatest generation it would have been
called that thing but you know compared
to that with Vietnam vets you know it's
a very different perception of how those
people were welcomed back into society
you know when they came home and treated
pioneers you're going home in here
Vietnam that your dad was in deep in
World War two or Korea you know it was
it was very different in terms of how it
was accepted right yeah
cities like one of the excerpts for
tomorrow is from oral histories from
women who served and on the other hand
they were very positive about their work
which mostly people in the book are
arming nurses but there are some who are
from American Friends Service Committee
they do get a couple of nurses letters
either one on the other hand very
positive and I think what the rhesus is
their vision was very clearly
articulated to them and much narrowly
learning early concede but on the other
hand when they came home they also liked
the man in return
a lot of trouble but for different
reasons because for them it was a very
high moment of expertise and over and
over all these people in this
that is in the readings of 26 oral
histories these women were able to do
things in Vietnam as nurses or in these
some of the jobs that when they came
home and were employed in hospitals or
whatever they were not able to do
they were not asked for that expertise
and they had to go into slots where it
wasn't wanted so they felt that they had
been able to do something
and that was a really different
experience yeah so you know the film I
think it was interesting because at the
time it was this data was collected in
the spring 2005 so this was body you
know dinging the second year after air
in Iraq - so the context of what she was
showing it was what was going on - was
really interesting in how students at
that point were reading it because of
what was going on in in contemporary
society because things were starting to
turn really even more quickly in Iraq
especially where this was again because
of the kind of the views in that in a
particular
87 it was put out so I and I don't know
much more about it in terms of you know
how they went about selecting the
letters or anything like that I think
that would be really interesting to find
out what you know how they went about it
it is interesting someone brought up you
know the thing I was good is the actors
like certain letters I don't notice but
like Shaun Ken's voice comes out clearly
and you're us De Niro's voice and then
you start thinking of bobert De Niro
olbia so there are some things that
flies with you a little bit easier as
you're listening these types of films do
you know when the movie coming home with
me no I'm just carry 78 that's what I
thought somebody that's late significant
that's a decade before this but you
definitely took the same perspective it
was really about the impact on people
coming home yeah what you would think is
to where was you know where would that
have been seen versus this I need to be
oh now so it's become much more accepted
by this point and that I mean that had
gained finally avoiding people who are
often seen as being you know very much
to the left who might have been people
who were
yeahthere's I might have said those were
the people calling the soldiers baby
killers but yeah actually took this
perspective yeah now that is interesting
Charlton Heston anti yet war documentary
the PBS doctor did you go to youtube you
can find I think it's called accuracy in
media and they say this is the real
Vietnam story and so it was made as a
response to the WGBH series that did
show prominently Jane Fonda in North
Vietnam on her infamous trip over there
and she's smiling and laughing and of
course you know you sure though they
chose those clips quite deliberately too
because she's you know
Eiling around with the Viet Cong but
it's worth checking out on YouTube to
see the reaction and they actually aired
it on PBS
because they picked up they really had
to because the tape of Charlton Heston
in this group and it wasn't the NRA but
was that this was a very biased piece
very biased documentary so they wanted
equal time to represent a more heroic
understanding
the war with their own set of villains
yeah and they tell me but it's not that
when sation use things like this in your
classroom in fact I think they should
because of what we're finding in terms
of the role in a film and media society
the thing is though you need to be more
explicit about this is one certain
perspective on it and help them to
understand how it reflects these are the
folks who made it or what's going on at
the time and then if you are going to
issue with with this particular classes
that this was the most this is the
biggest source of information maybe
these their textbook a little bit on
Vietnam that they used and they said
well now you need to make up your mind
on how you would stand on this issue
using this one film okay yeah that's a
little bit different because you're
saying this is an open question but yet
you're feeding them the right answer
basically by giving this to them as the
only source so that's kind of the issue
it's more of a pedagogical one then
actually showing video would be
interesting to show this and then show
the Charlton Heston one that's
comparison and have them compare the two
films in terms of the views of the head
or something you know so it's it's
emailing not anti using films at all
it's just you need to be careful I think
more so just be aware of the things that
you bring me into your classroom so this
one is the last activity I'm gonna try
to get to do this with humans for
questions enable just works box first
part of it the front page of it that has
the were looking at perspectives
hearings where I watch a short clip of
Aaron Morris's film fog of war which was
centered around Robert McNamara who you
saw a little bit earlier in the clip
that bill showed and what I want you to
do is this is a really good one for
looking at what evidence is the
documentary filmmaker using to make
their case and this one is multiple
perspectives on it because you've got
McNamara
expected being kind of as he's being
interviewed he's able to tell his story
then you have another layer of Errol
Morris's perspective on it by the way
he's structuring the documentary it's
interesting because it is largely the
interview with one person but it's easy
to see kind of these two levels of how
McNamara's message is being frames or
just going to watch a little bit of it
and meaning I want you to pay attention
okay this is good practice because we
wanted to be a job while you're feeling
sorry I'm looking at this professor it's
really look at what types of evidence is
the filmmaker using to either support or
what's his message along with McNamara's
okay I'm gonna stop there right watching
mekka Larry just let's keep talking so
think about it for a second what types
of evidence is Morris using here to try
to get his point across
what did you see in there you have the
testimonial from McNamara telling the
story what else
you have the phone the phone
conversations right what else is he
doing kind of visually and with the
music to try to get a certain message
across to you yes I'm trying over what
they described it's Philip Glass who
does a lot of these films something
dread it doesn't this kind of dreadful
dune approaching right definitely but
it's like it's not the doing the torpedo
if they do of this of this sequence of
events that we were wrong the time and
the date and so you know there's like
build up to a climax and I feel like a
lot of television police shows these
days use the same you know sort of
method method yeah in terms of its
structure it's not it's these are the
newer documentaries right they're taking
on a little bit different structure in
terms of how they're framed and how
they're telling the story now you saw
some of the same stock footage in here
that you did in the earlier series if
you notice from this morning to which is
interesting the planes taking off from
the carrier one of the destroyer just
showing the radar Hut going around what
else do you notice though do you think
they really have a can
they're in the sonar men on that day
knowing that there's going to be attack
coming
no okay probably like a training film or
something do they really have the ones
of those particular torpedoes coming at
them well of course not because the
torpedoes didn't exist although I do
love the backwards torpedo coming up the
end kind of is we're taking back that
look right yeah okay so you have to
think about when you see the
documentaries what are all the pieces of
evidence that they're using to kind of
build this in here you had some real
kind of you know primary sources of
things in terms of the phone calls are
being used in terms of a couple of the
documents that are used and highlighted
and selected from the try to make the
case to either support or refute what
McNamara's saying right but if you also
notice when you're watching McNamara
this is a little blood this is Errol
Morris manthis and he uses a seven
something he designed he calls it the
enteric Truong I know if you ever seen
any of their losses documentaries but if
you know it's looking directly at you
into the camera he designed a device
where basically Errol Marcia's image
comes up over the camera so when he
interviews them you're looking they're
people being interviewed look directly
into the camera and so it gives you this
really straight arms a little unnerving
and so Air Force is actually sitting
right next to the camera but he's got
the set of mirrors that shows him so
wouldn't when they were answering the
questions they answer directly to the
camera so it also sets you off a little
bit that McNamara's a little creepy
looking anyway he's staring at you in
that way one of the things that people
notice about that someone cutting a
little bit short on this section so but
you do have two perspectives here
because you have McNamara who's telling
a story he was trying to get out a
little bit of the blame here for some of
it saying that they're still justified
on the first day even though they're
wrong in the second attack right but
then yo Meryl Moritz kind of putting the
story together in a certain way using
the music to raise questions using these
other phone calls you know building it
in so you've kind of got two layers here
and in a number of documentaries here I
see that you're gonna see multiple
perspectives in that kind of the
perspectives of the people who are being
interviewed in there and then how those
perspectives are being used to get into
this bigger overall story of what's
there - and Morris was really criticized
they said that he let McNamara off kind
of in this building he wasn't critical
enough of McNamara and so that's another
interesting thing is to read some of the
reviews of how it was received because
in many people's mind
they knew McNamara you know from that
generation as you know the devil
reincarnate
called the voice of God
narration yeah which was like the
third-person narrator of anomalistic
and it just had this omniscient voice
and I think everybody I don't know kids
in class might be too young to remember
too many of those but you know just
third-person narration but the new kind
has all the talking heads more
interviews more sub you know or so and
then they set off one interview
perspective against another engineer
perspective and then they use these
devices like putting the on screening
type which sort of reinforces you know
the voice that's coming and gives it a
double weight it's interesting some
about three filmmakers of are open and
transparent what they're doing and some
are in this one you have to hear more
yelling at them from behind the you know
sometimes you do everything well why'd
you do that you know you hear me
shouting at mcnamara from it and another
one they still want to keep kind of the
interviewer like there's no one there
that's actually asking the person
questions like this story is just coming
on naturally and so it is interesting to
get students to think about that and
some new documentaries are much more
transparent even most saying really
there's one called banish which is about
these towns most of red in the south
where basically african-americans we're
just booted out of town and in that one
the guy who makes it who's named Mel
slipping me it's the same guy that did
the two towns of Jasper Texas and those
I can't
Tomic had I meet the press over at NYU
though I filled it he's actually in the
film interviewing the people and asking
them to tell the story of using it so
it's much more transparent in that
there's some you know pulling the story
out that they have a role in the film in
the making of the film and so I think
you're seeing more of that in some
documentaries although a lot still are
the kind of over narration that's
basically telling you the truth
that you should listen to because it is
this kind of an island you know that in
the beginning but goes here too the way
he's explaining what the resolution was
you know comparing what we're talking
about this morning to in terms of why
they did it in that way in terms of the
authority in that too so if you looked
across the again if you could search
multiple documentaries for how they all
compare or talk about that one incident
and go across to be really interesting
than if students look at why are the
different perspectives out there because
of the evidence that's available because
of you know the time when it was done
because of who they talked to you know
would be really interesting to see
GBH series so remember our market
Maurice do you know why and so you know
so far maybe someone will be able to
tell us before the project is done but
it is we don't have an answer now
considered such a herd but this would be
interesting to juxtapose with the WGBH
because because he's accent in and again
this is made at a time you know title
the fog of war because again we're
seeing Afghanistan Iraq when this comes
out as you know you could read this as a
you know a little bit of a critique on
that obviously as well or at least
raising some issues about it so again
looking at the time when something is
produced as well as always you know what
is it really about the amount or is it
about something else
you might have seen over the years
finally decided well he'd written a book
and this is the same title as the book
the 11 lessons from whatever it is
something like that so I think he
probably saw it is which the book I
think was for him to was kind of his
chance to tell his story and that's also
probably why errol morris didn't go too
critical on this as he wanted people to
kind of decide for themselves and
package it in this way as my gasp okay
I'm gonna stop there to give us a couple
minutes or questions literally sorry
any questions I threw a punch at you
I apologize without giving you much time
for reflection but I want to give you
some ideas of how you can think about
using things in your own classrooms and
also as you're selecting your own films
what to think about
is very support
so I'm both washable decided my brother
so effectively even more effectively and
then you're right that the challenge
becomes educating them about the blue
where's the narratives being manipulated
that's within the other narrative but
because the connection is so visceral
how do you remember that footage of all
those boys in Vietnam looking completely
Hollow UN and as the narrative builds
the case that this was totally
meaningless and these couples knew they
were dying for no reason you know how do
you deal with teenagers in the classroom
faced with that you know how have you
there's an emotional response or a
psychological response ability of
educator yeah I think the one thing that
I found there's a couple things I see
anything is usually class and just hang
on them right they don't discuss that
they don't do anything I mean the fact
the other day I saw this is a little
horrifying this is Virginia but they
spent three days and watching one of my
student teachers was in process spent
three days watching Jesus Christ
Superstar did what everybody start Jesus
and then 30 minutes all the world
religions let that one go but so I see
because I do this research now I hear
people tell me all these little horror
stories or or how ten commandments is
used to teach about ancient Israeli
history which is another one I heard or
you know all these ones and then I'm
kind of going you know but I hear all
these things because this is my research
area so I think film is a really tricky
one in that but the two things that
really found one is that in order to
have a good discussion students need to
be really well prepared to have that
discussion right so that's what's drawn
me to use to play with these different
kind of instruments during the viewing
to give us doing the job with what we're
gonna have in mind at the end so if you
think of the Socratic seminar you have
them do some kind of a ticket to prepare
for the discussion same thing here so
what you want to talk about was well
what is the social what was the impact
on these young people as a result of
this war this wasn't just Vietnam right
we've all kinds of things now in the
world war two that soldiers came back
with all forms of PTSD just no one
talked about it right and all the wars
we probably had these things but Vietnam
they became kind of really central to it
because of the type of war it was some
degree too so however you can frame them
to prepare them for the discussion you
can so what are you going to have them
do during the viewing that will give
them the information and prepare them to
look at it in a certain way that then
you can discuss it and what I'm saying
that is you need to add on that extra
layer though so you're not just talking
about what's portrayed in the film but
the film itself okay we sometimes get
torn we get all up into what's going on
in the film story not looking at the
bigger picture so how is it framed in
society you know how does it reflect the
time and the people who made it and all
those things and this chronic seminar
works well because that's what you're
doing when you do literature that way
right you're not just talking about the
story or whatever you read you're also
talking about the author why did the
white adopter do this or that
so in my mind that's why I've been doing
a lot of this kind of modified versions
of those seminars but it takes time so
the thing I was telling is that you're
going to choose to show something you
know this is why I don't think clips are
necessarily a bad idea
unless you do want to give them the idea
of kind of that narrative arc across
something but you need to take the time
then to help them debrief it because you
are going to get different perspectives
on it from a whole wide variety as you
can imagine that letters home from
Vietnam I had some young boys who are in
that class going wow you know I'm
getting one read on it while other kids
were absolutely horrified by the
violence in it so you're going to get
that wide range of perspectives across
it's good for students to hear each
other's perspectives on it so yeah so
that's I'm kind of not answering your
question but the big thing is you know
really in terms of taking the time to
debrief and discuss it which takes a lot
of time and so I tell my students if
you're picking a feature film or
feature-length documentary you're
talking an hour and a half you know two
three class periods to get through it
plus another one for discussion is it
really worth it you know or should you
be spending your time on other things or
can you use a short clip from it and
have pasted this pretty close to same
effect yeah
so you're probably in the notion of any
objectivity remembered through
documentaries and I think that's very
valuable now that we have the capacity
to take out the soundtrack and to go
back to the raw materials and to see
what the director didn't use the
temptation is to regard that as more
active access to objectivity that we
didn't have before and wonder what your
reaction to that is well I mean you
still are asking certain questions they
picked those people for surgeries right
I mean you still have a number of
choices even going into the interviews
that were there but you know compare a
weird time on this earlier to see what
was left out of that you know if you
watched part of that series of where
maybe that person was an interview you
picked a segment that they did include
the interview from and then you watch
some of the raw footage of what else
they said I think that's a really
powerful thing in terms of talking about
why did the filmmaker decide that was
the part to pull out from it you know I
think I think it can be really useful
the other thing you know that this
project and some of the other ones I've
heard that are similar is having
students create their own documentaries
from some of this stuff would be really
interesting because then the hope would
be that then they would understand more
of those choices that they made in
creating their owns that when they
looked at other documentaries they would
get a better sense of what went into
making it - so I think you know I think
you still can't say it's it's objective
because there are still going to be you
know again they're asking the questions
and it's given within a certain context
but I think it's more raw more primary
than it would be in a finished product
for sure it'd be the same way in that a
primary a diary or something all a
little bit less because the diaries
going to be more of that person's
thoughts and not sure
and my questions from somewhere else but
you know it is someone the same way